this is Meg from fandango movie clips
with things to know before you see
ant-man like if you're expecting Paul
Rudd to go all Jeff Goldblum spoiler
you're going to be disappointed a man
marks the end of phase 2 in the MCU the
Marvel Cinematic Universe duh it stars
Paul Rudd as Scott Lang AKA ant-man
Michael Douglas portrays Hank Pym the
old ant-man I mean the original ant-man
regardless the man has page like fine
wine basically dr. Hank Pym approaches
his mentee an ex-con Lang with a
proposition to get back in the saddle
execute a heights that will save the
world how will I pull it off obviously
by dying an arm super suit that shrinks
them into the size of an ant how else in
the comics pins ant-man is the original
adventure Lang's ant-man is just a
regular old superhero now the cast also
includes Corey's skull as antagonists
Darren cross AK yellow jacket and
Evangeline Lilly as Hank pimps daughter
hope Van Dyne who may or may not be the
loss I'm stoked how much Marvel is
loving comedic directors and writers and
managed directed by Peyton Reed director
bring it on yes man and the breakup and
written by every comedic writer in the
biz Edgar Wright Joe Cornish Adam McKay
and Paul Rudd turns out an ant costume
can be pretty badass besides having the
ability to shrink a man down to the size
of an ant it also provides laying with
super strength and stamina finally
proving size doesn't matter it's not the
size of the hero it's how you use them
or her also laying cybernetic helmet
allows them to communicate with insects
um that doesn't sound very badass well
whatever it's an awesome combination of
iron man's helmet an Autobot transformer
bumblebee Paul Rudd pulled a chris pratt
and got real fit for the role Michael
Douglas stated Rudd suit was altered
because his ripped bod was bursting out
of it from all this intense training the
VFX team took special measures to create
an interesting new take on shrinking
flicks macro photography and motion
capture is used to give the film a more
experimental vibe that means it's gonna
look great in fancy film talk and for
all you haters who think ant-man is
going to flop get used to his tiny face
Marvel has already announced that Paul
Rudd will be reprising
his role in next year's Civil War
possible end credits scenes might shed
some light on what's to come the super
year Registration Act Scott Lang being
recruited by Tony starring him but being
recruited by general Ross Scott laying
being recruited by the cat Black
Panthers reveals your strangest reveals
Spidey joining the crew layin him
rattling superhero needs a call back to
Thomas the Tank but knowing paul rudd
he'll probably just show that clip from
mac and me
I'm beg from fandango movie clips thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and go see ant-man and feeders and just
remember next time you see an ant don't
step on it it could be a superhero